that that Ted stun turn dad this week
I've set some more and Lucy a little bit
of a challenge since we all been excited
to replay cod4 in the remastered version
we're going to race the final epilogue
mission mile-high club on the hard and
difficulty first person to get the VIP
off the plane wins you can use any
controller you want any strategy you
want just save that VIP and the fastest
time starting with tomorrow alright I'm
ready to do this it's been a while since
I've done mile-high club I reckon the
thing that's going to get me is going to
be the time limit but let's do this
I've already started wrong I don't know
who's who've already oh no that is not
how is meant to go it's just keyboard
I'm blaming this keyboard I'm blaming
this keyboard I'm thinking that I'm
gonna do it for sit with hip-fire oh no
it's not gonna work
gob dad yep I'm dead I'm safe I'm dead I
was all right there no no I'm gonna
toilet oh god I needed to pee Oh guys
guys go go
he's got me what what that we're real
bad real fast
No stop hitting me I'm a good guy
oh great Blanding myself brilliant good
job saltimbocca finish the biscuit man
Oh God whoa okay so there's two dudes at
the top of the stairs I'll remember that
for next time
killin with my melee attack Oh God
what am I looking at here what's going
on
nope screw it
yes oh my god move yeah kill the dude
what oh oh wait hold on
I'm not gonna shoot him again I shot
that guy in the head there's no way good
where's the bomb where's the bomb oh
[ __ ]
easy that was nothing it took me only
like four or five tries so I'm trying to
use my overwatch strats and see how that
plays out for me come on lads
what is it for to throw a grenade a
grenade on a plane Oh God
I have played myself stairway stay
always do it Oh what what the hell did
you shoot me with you son of a [ __ ] son
of a [ __ ] okay
13 seconds oh no how do I run of me I
mean all up
this isn't over watch this isn't over
lunch I wish this was over watch mate
what no you oh it's crouched I need to
get to the target how do I run shift Oh
dear me
okay oh no no I thought he was down
lobotomy down Hey oh wow what no god of
mate blows I can feel it I can taste the
VIP
no oh come on
don't know who I shot let's try not to
kill the VIP this time knife in there oh
my God look how fast that one was all
right let's kill the right guy
get that whack see into a duck dick
killed someone did I get him get him
I did hi buddy
exit plane how all right bye
like to apologize to my parents for the
swear word I hope you don't watch this
all right so I have gone with keyboard
and mouse it's one most familiar with
because I'm an elite gamer one minute
fish gets oiler go get that guy all
these dudes just come thundering in
except
dead already that madman just charged me
nail me the butt of his rifle then suit
conserve a bit of ammo for a flashy and
turn around so I don't flash myself
flash myself a little bit
oh I didn't see you in the corner there
sneaky bugger I don't want to actually
ditch my pistol but it's too late to go
back for it I'm sorry pistol I'm sorry
they all nice need lineup for me there
you dead you're not dead you're not dead
all right this one I feel this one that
that that stun turn dad pistol
my Pinay is the perfect weapon for this
little section because it's got all the
bullets shooting through the wall don't
care if it's cheesy
get all the way it's gonna get Sodor
black dad I miss black you kidding me
I'm shooting the legs then if I can't
get your head shot god damn it
I go go go just get open the door open
the door but the door time stops as soon
as the door opens reach it reach it
reach it there you go
bye time time okay wasn't so bad